[Music]
welcome to the iron lords podcast
all right and we are live ironworld's
podcast watchinggaming.net
and we are in the room who is this fine
gentleman in the round today
i'm doing very well i'm william very
nice to meet you all thank you for
coming on focus on today in my booth
today
i'll be taking a bit about chance of
scenario
would that be all right yeah that would
be awesome okay so all right okay
what is your role with chances for that
okay so i am an associate line producer
at focus entertainment so i'm not
following this game normally but i'm the
one in charge
for intensive cinema yeah
so i know pretty much every everything
you need to know we like that
i can be of some help i guess here oh
you could be great so this game is a
point-and-click puzzle game so
basically you're controlling this little
guy here let's get right into it
you take a driver's seat
you are controlling this little fella
here
and the the aim of the game is to
understand
the languages the different languages
there are in the game and basically how
to communicate with people and they'll
make you understand the role you have in
the game okay so
this little fella here is the main
character and you can go to someone to
talk to that person
and you have glyphs basically everywhere
so we're a bit in in the in the demo
okay so it means that we have already
started understanding some of the clips
gotcha so for example we know that this
is closed door so we know this glyph and
this one and we still need to find what
it is all about about these two
so you can move around basically with
your mouse as an important game and you
have your journal that you can access
here okay so basically that's why you
saw information you can guess basically
from the start you know nothing
is no good right you know nothing just
knows so all right you can type a guess
here for example that could be i don't
know worship for example so i type
worship and i have a guess at this level
i don't know if it's all right now if
it's the exact translation but i can
guess and in here i have the exact
meaning so i stole the information in my
journal and then when i put the glyphs
at the right spot
i have the correct meaning that helps me
understand the language and then the
universe now let me ask you this
question as you
try to decipher these glyphs and get
more understanding now do these things
actually like are that open or progress
puzzles or like places you can go like
what's the purpose once you actually
solve something from a good standpoint
how what does it advance gameplay-wise
okay
so
normally the puzzles and the riddles
make you understand
the glyphs and when you do it will allow
you and the players to understand the
universe and your role gotcha so it's
all basically a very elegant game design
ideas gotcha that is linking rituals and
puzzles with the languages
okay to make you understand your role
because this is okay
this is behind the scene information
let's go yeah exclusive what's the case
we have a first language here
so this is just a normal
man or a devotee with a given language
but i can go up to this warrior here
and you'll see that this is a different
language altogether
so you can see that now i have a
different language
and so basically there are new glyphs
so it means that people in this world
they're not necessarily capable of
talking to each other okay because
that's different languages
and so we can infer that i will have a
special role in this game because my aim
is to master all five languages gotcha
so maybe i'll be the only one
able to understand everyone
and so that would maybe provide me with
a big role now let me ask you some
background questions as far as the main
character the the over altering
narrative as far as putting putting
these languages together we're trying to
connect things but what is this person's
role in the story
that would be a major back seat so huh
i'm going
okay i'm going too deep so basically
this will be revealed
exactly
okay so this would be really
providing all of the late game
information and i think that's really a
shame so i don't know
we keep that for the play but basically
you have an important role to play but
the game will explain it as itself it
will explain to you
through the languages you discover and
the glyphs you're gonna call it gotcha
now one thing i really like and
appreciate about the game is the art
style it's a very stylish and when you
say this associated like what what's
tell me about the the graphical design
is this using unity unreal what are we
using from that stuff
well to my knowledge this is unity okay
it's just a two-man team wow doing
part-time job on this one so two french
men
which are really talented as you can see
oh yes and it's just
it's quite i would say challenging
because you're not always in this sort
of a
3d isometric view it's not only top down
it can be much more zoomed out so it's
nearly camera rails and camera
approaches which are very different from
one screen to another right so that's
really
a big challenge for this project and it
makes it very refreshing yeah it's it's
a very different one from another i
really like it i would love you to keep
progressing so i can see more
of the of the world so for example
we could infer that this one is me
because i i've played the game so that
would make sense
that would help and if this is me right
all right so he's pointing and
assembling he's got to be me yeah and he
says
so that should work right and if it's
not it's the other way around
and so we thought that it was greetings
and it is greetings and this one is me
actually and this one is you so i'm
finding more words here
and then i can for example
play a card game here because the main
gameplay is just pointedly going from
screen to screen but you actually have
some
gameplay within the gameplay okay you
have a card game here which is basically
to help you understand how the different
roles played with each other
so
here for example i have chosen a warrior
and he picked sort of a normal man and
since the warrior is high in society i
have won this round i won this round so
basically like a hierarchy a societal
hierarchy based on the cards okay
exactly and this is very linked sort of
a tower of cable or something like this
yeah we're trying just to reach the top
and
it's very hierarchy based nice and so
it's very so what's going what's going
on with the abacus looking thing
i'm curious
what's that about but it's just a game
and you're trying to have the the the
overhand in the game so you try to play
against the opponents and to have the
biggest the most powerful card
on the on the ball and so when you play
you had a lot of glyphs everywhere and
now you found about this clip you have
new
possibilities here and then you can
infer what i would say for example what
could that be this one here what lives
could that be here
kind of thing there's
so many that we could think about as far
as what could be as far as just its
action structure itself i mean
i don't even know where to go with it to
be honest that would be a warrior okay
yeah he's the warrior clearly so that
would be a warrior right that makes
sense
okay so we can put the warrior here
so what is it son of a deity a god
something yeah like some deity god like
girls or deity all right
so we can put it there
that would be one a normal man just a
man yeah
okay normal man all right let's type in
it
and what would that be some sort of a
religious people religious figure priest
or something
all right priest
wow
i guess okay okay
the other man a devotee devotee now wait
i gotta stab you now said priest right
so what does the algorithm
kind of fit to what's similar in style
to what the glyph could be because we
didn't get a one-to-one match so i'm
just curious as how that algorithm
worked
well it's actually always the same
answers at a given time okay but the
game is on purpose allowing you to just
progress
as you see it fits or how you want to as
you want to understand so you're not
blocked by the game because you have
mismatched the glitch
because you're just far off gotcha you
can be way far off and at some time just
just randomly choose a glyph and find an
answer and that's the way of discovering
the game or just making headway no i get
it it's very flexible it's flexible
gotcha but it will always be the same
answers gotcha in any game you might
make that's really cool it's really cool
too you take it one thing that i
appreciate about it is that
it to me it's really kind of teaching
you about different cultures and and
trying to understand
you almost have like a hieroglyphic
aspect of it from the glyph standpoint
and you have like a culture and language
aspect of it there's a lot of different
moving parts to it but it's really cool
because it doesn't hold your hand but
it's not blocking you to the point where
you have to be so specific exactly
so we can move move around a bit
i'm just amazed to see that this is just
a work of art yeah it's two people the
art style is beautiful for two people
two people really it's a very charming
game very charming art style
so you have that indicator someone's
coming out oh
someone's here to talk to us
you me okay so you need to pay attention
to the animation so this little guy here
said
come with me and run away
here we go playing with it
is there maybe a bit more we want to
know about this game or yeah absolutely
i mean any more than sure because i mean
the things about it now as far as from a
level design as far as um
progression right now once we start
unlocking more things you know i know a
lot of the
character backstory is shrouded in
mystery
but i do want to know from a progression
standpoint is it level based is it is a
certain amount of levels you get to or
is it something that it's just still
organic within this one scope of world
and you're just
moving around this one particular area
in the world
it's as you said you're the second
option it's very i would say world-based
okay it's as you as we said we mentioned
the tower of abel which is quite a good
example for this game and you're just
going from
one
level of the tower okay which is really
defined by
the aesthetics basically the colors you
have so you have it's very it's really
color coded based in this game with very
warm color in the front at the beginning
and you're going to evolve it's a
very complete different experience and
so very world-based but the transitions
are are very elegant again awesome
awesome you ever love in the art style
absolutely impressed that this is just
the work of two people and we are
looking forward to more chances this is
really cool so as far as platforms what
are we looking at and how close maybe to
release
okay so asking the real questions
so as far as i know you can see that we
plan on releasing on the nintendo switch
on pc nice so obviously when we think
about the nintendo switch obviously
there are sort of two versions of the
switch handheld and dots yeah so it's an
actual challenge for the game and
something we're really looking forward
and looking at
uh we plan on ship shipping that's
important for us okay shipping so it's
nintendo switch from the pc
potential uh time frame of
possible uh that would be very cool that
would be too dangerous for me
if i said this
they've really refined what they wanted
to make and now we're in production
awesome and the studio i want to mention
this because it's important for us
please we're helping the developers but
we really want to
praise the developers for what they've
done here so let's run this
yes little logo you see here
two french people which are really doing
an amazing job on this game that's
awesome we're really looking forward to
what they can produce
and uh more more to come really more to
come and more information is coming
looking for these states don't leave
them down but switch pc
run this
very charming very unique very unique
game art style the glyphs deciphering
language culture we're really looking
forward to it thank you for your time
again
absolute pleasure
a pleasure
check this out chance of scenario
a little underrated jam keep your eye on
it cheers
[Music]
you